[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد قال رايس مجلس السياده
الانتقاليه السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان
قال بحضور القيادات العسكريه والمدنيه ان
الجيش استجابه للشعب بمدنيه الحكم مشددا
على ان المؤسسه العسكريه الاصليه وليس لها
بديل ولا توجد قوه تحل محلها في اشاره
لقوات الدعم السريع واضاف البرهان ان هناك
قوه سياسيه مدنيه تحاول خلق بدلاء للجيش
لتمرير اجنده ولن ينجحوا لان المقلد لن
يصمد ويكون اصيلا لانه ليس له منشا بحسب
تعبيره متعهدا بترك المجال للقوى السياسيه
الحقيقيه وليست المزيفه او التي تستعين
بالبدائل والخوالف على حد تعبيره من جهته
جزمه عضو مجلس السياده ياسر العطاء بان
القوات المسلحه ليس لها مطامع في حكم
البلاد ولا تستخدم التكتيكه السياسيه
للاستمرار فيها وتؤمن بالانتقالات
الديمقراطي وتداول السلطه سلميا وشدد
العطاء على ضروره توافق قوى الثوره من اجل
بناء مؤسسه دوليه قويه لا تتعرض للابتزاز
من قبل ميليشيات او جيوش خارجه سيطرتها
نحن عندنا اليات وعندنا تنظيمات وجهات
مسؤوله من تنفيذ مظالم الناس اولا نحن
حنسعى بنعلم مستوى ان كل مشكله
وبتتعالج بورق بكتابه اذا كان تعديل لا
قوانين لروائح لنظم لكل شيء ده حق الناس
نحن ما حنتاخر فيه ولا حنجيب فيه مما جئنا
سمعنا هتاف الناس وسمعنا كلام الناس انه
جيش واحد شعب واحد حق الجيش ده حقكم انتم
ما حق اي زول ثاني ولا حد جانا ولا حق زيد
ولا حق عبيد عشان كذا لما قلنا حنجيب
الاسعافات هنجيب من الجيش العربيه
الاداريه حنجيبها من الجيش العبارات حتقطع
الناس حنجيبها من الجيش القلابات
اربعه قلابات وحنجيب لوادر حنجيبهم من
الجيش
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من الخرطوم
الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين المحلل
العسكري ومن الخرطوم كذلك شريف محمد عثمان
الامين السياسي لحزب المؤتمر السوداني
والمتحدث باسم الحريه والتغيير اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا معك فريق
فتح الرحمن
في الواقع خلينا نحاول ان نقطل الموضوع
لانه ما قيل فيما قبل عن الخلافات بين
الطرفين البرهان وحميدتي مع حفظ الالقاب
بيت واقع وبيت ظاهر وبيت صريح في هذه
المرحله ولكن ما مدى ثقل هذه الاسماء ما
مدى عمق هذه الهوه بين طرفين
في البدايه التحيه لك والتحيه للاخ شريف
للساده المتابعين وانا شاكر جدا على هذه
الاستضافه وانا حقيقه اقول اننا يعني خلال
الاسبوع الماضي يعني استبشرنا اخيرا ان
التباين السياسي بين السيد رئيس مجلس
السياده ونائبو تقريبا انتفى وعاده اللحمه
من جديد ولكن للاسف ما شاهدناه يعني
بالامس وما سمعناه من الناطق الرسمي باسم
العمليه السياسيه في انهم ماضون الى
الاتفاق النهائي بهذا الشكل انا اعتقد
انهم ايضا بهذا الاتفاق النهائي اذا مضى
بهذا الشكل سيدفع بالخلاف من جديد وسيدفع
بالتباين السياسي ما بين رئيس مجلس
السياده ونائب من جديد وقد تنجر العمليه
الى ابعد من ذلك يعني لان الشيء الذي كان
متفقا عليه ان هذه التوقيتات صحيحه الجيش
يؤمن عليها ان تبدا من الاول من ابريل
وحتى
من ابريل لكن بشرط ان تكون الكتله
الديمقراطيه ضمن الغور السياسيه المدنيه
الموجوده في هذا الاتفاق وكان من المامول
ان تحضر الكتله الديمقراطيه اجتماع الامس
في المساء بالقصر ولكن الديمقراطيه اعتزلت
عن هذا الحضور وكان اصلا قد صبغه اجتماع
في وسط النهار لنفس الذين وقعوا الاتفاق
الايطالي مع المكون العسكري والتوافقوا
على هذه الجداول الزمنيه فكان ينبغي ان
تعرض هذه الجداول الزمنيه على الكتله
الديمقراطيه في اجتماع النساء ولكن اعتزلت
الكتله الديمقراطيه للتحفظات ان الدعوه
كانت انتهائيه لاجزاء منها وليس لكل
الكتله وكان من المامول ان يؤجل هذا
الاجتماع لانه هكذا يعني مضى وما سمعناه
من الناطق الرسمي للعمليه السياسيه في
اننا سنمضي الى تشكيل لجنه او سكنت لجنه
لكي تصير الاتفاق النهائي لكي تعرضه في 26
مارس انا هذا يعني تجاوز صحيح ولكن اسمح
لي فريق فريق فتح الرحمن
في فتره الانتقاليه التي يقود البلاد الى
مهددات امنيه خطيره هذه هي الخطوره التي
نحن نتحدث بها للاخوه في مركزيات الحريه
والتغيير يجب ان يتنازلوا يجب ان تكون
الدعوه شامله لكل القوه السياسيه التي
تؤمن بالتغيير حتى نخرج من هذا المازق
وحتى لا نجر البلاد الا تداعيات امنيه
خطيره تجر البلاد الى ما لا تحمد عقبه طيب
القيت الكره في ملعب الحريه والتغيير
استاذ شريف تتحملون مسؤوليه هذه الاخفاقات
كما يقول
الفريق فتح الرحمن
اولا مساء الخير عليك وعلى اضافه الكريم
سعاده الفريق عبد فتح الرحمن وكل
المتابعين الكرام طبعا هو سؤال مردود يعني
ما فهمتوا من سياق حديثه انه ان الغياب
الكتله الديمقراطيه سيتوتر العلاقه ما بين
ما بين الجانبين
جيش وقائد الدعم السريع وانا ما عارف هي
ما هي الصله والمشتركات التي تجعل غياب
الكتله الديمقراطيه هي سبب في هذا في هذا
التوتر هذا الحديث طبعا غير صحيح واشاره
غير صحيحه الازمه هي الازمه اشاره لها
المدنيين مع قبل انقلاب 25 اكتوبر ان واحد
من التحديات التي تواجه السودان هي قضيه
تعدد الجيوش والانقسام داخل المؤسسه
الامنيه وهو ما نعمل الان مع الطرفين على
ترتيب هذا الوضع واستعاد وايجاد صيغه
متوافق حولها لبناء جيش وطني واحد عبر دمج
الدعم السريع داخل القوات المسلحه
بالاضافه
الى عمليه اصلاح للقوات المسلحه وتحديث
للقوات المسلحه هذا الامر يجب الان النقاش
فيه ولا اعتقد ان هذا الامر هو ان الحديث
عن الكتله الديمقراطيه وغيابها الاجتماعيه
تسبب النزاع ما بين قاعده الجيش وقائد
الاعدامه الحديث غير صحيح
بالامس كل القضايا والموضوعات التي مضت
حتى اعلان معلنه الناطق الرسمي والعمليه
السياسيه الباشمهندس خالد عمر يوسف مساء
امس حول المواريث والجداول الزمنيه التي
تم التوافق عليها كل هذه القضايا يتم
مناقشتها بكل وضوح وبكل شفافيه مع كل
اطراف العمليه السياسيه قائد القوات
المسلحه السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد
الدعم السريع الفريق والحميتي وكذلك القوه
الموقعه للاتفاق على الاطاري ما فيها
واعلان الحريه والتغيير وهو خارج الحريه
والتغيير كل هذه الاطراف تجتمع بشكل راتب
وتناقش هذه القضايا وتصل فيها لتوافق فرمي
اللوم على ان هذه الاطراف غير متوافقه هذا
الامر يتم التوافق مع قائد هذه الاطراف
وحتى تحديد المقدس صحيح ولكن حضرتك تتحدث
عن نقطه جدا مهمه اتفضل اكمل اتفضل نقطه
صغيره نقطه صغيره نقطه صغيره نقطه صغيره
وحتى تحديد اطراف العمليه سياسيه من هي
القوه الموقعه على هذا على الاتفاق
النهائي وما هي اطراف العمليه السياسيه
هذا الامر تم الاتفاق فيه مع غايه الجيش
وقائد الدعم السريع فتحميل المسؤوليه
للحريه والتغيير وللمجلس المركزي هذا هذا
التحميل هذه المسؤوليه هذا امر غير صحيح
اذا كانت هناك سمه مسؤوليه يتحملها قائد
الجيش وقاعده الدعم السريع وكل الاطراف
التي توافقت على الاطراف العمليه السياسيه
وعلى مواغيتها وعلى المرجعيات التي ستبنى
عليها الاتفاق النهائي يعني المشكله قد
تكون اعمق من هذا
فريق
المشكله او في كيف سيتم الاتفاق على هذا
المسار ولكن هناك مؤسس حقيقي منقسم على
نفسه ونتحدث عن المؤسسه العسكريه هناك عدم
توافق كلي بين الجيش والدعم السريع وضيفي
يقول لك بانه هذه هي النقطه الرئيسيه هذا
مربط الفرس هذا محل الخلاف الحقيقي
يا عزيزتي هذا الخلاف اصلا السبب فيه
مركزيه الحريه والتغيير او الذين وقعوا
على الاتفاق الايطالي من المكون المدني
انا اشرح لك كيف ذلك ذلك بان الان الان
اذا ما اصرت القوه التي وقعت في الاتفاق
الايطالي ان تمضي للاتفاق النهائي دون ان
تصطحب معها الكتله الديمقراطيه هذا يعني
ان القوات المسلحه لن توافق على الاتفاق
النهائي والدعم السريع سيوافق على الدعم
النهائي وانا متاكد من ذلك وبالامس عندما
تحدث السيد رئيس مجلس السياده انا اعتقد
انه السيد رئيس المجلس السياده لا يمكن ان
يتحدث عن فراغ وانما يتحدث من منطلق
معلومات مؤكده لديه الذين يدعوا الى ايجاد
بديل للقوات المسلحه لكي يمضي بالعمليه
السياسيه للامام هذا حديث واضح وصريح انهم
يعمقوا الخلاف ما بين القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع وهذا امر خطير جدا على
البلاد وخطير جدا على العمليه السياسيه
برمتها الشيء الاخر نحن استمعنا اليوم الى
مؤتمر صحفي
الكتله الديموقراطيه وكان حديثها واضحا
انها موافقه تماما على ان تمضي في العمليه
السياسيه للامام ولكن لا يمكن ان تمضي تحت
وسايه مركزيه الحريه والتغيير لا يمكن ان
تمضي وهي
اليد السفلى وهما اليد العليا ان يرتبوا
كل شيء ويصيغه كل شيء ثم تاتي الكتله
الديموقراطيه هكذا لتكمل العدد يعني هذا
شيء غير مقبول ونحن نحترم هذا الراي فيهم
وانا والله استمعت للمؤتمر الصحفي اليوم
كلهم تحدثوا بروح وطنيه عاليه جدا يعني
يعلو قيمه الوطن حقيقه وواضح جدا ان ليس
لديهم اي اجندات خلاف حل الازمه السياسيه
انا اعتقد انه
عليهم عليهم ان يستمعوا لهؤلاء الاخوه
الشعارات فيما افيد التصريحات ان كان
الاساس مفقود ان كان ليس هناك
نيه حقيقيه وجلوس حقيقي للمذي قدما للدفع
حقيقه بهذا المسار
اذا هذا هو ما نتحدث عنه الذين وقع في
الاتفاق الايطالي عليهم ان يبعدوا
الاجندات الخاصه عليهم ان يعلو قيمه الوطن
عليهم ان يتوافقوا مع الاخرين ويوسعوا
قائده المشاركه لكي تنضم الفطر الانتقاليه
للامام وليضعوا في في
مخيلتهم انهم بعد ان يتوافقوا مع الكتله
الديمقراطيه هنالك مغامه سيواجهونها من
الذين يزرعوا الى التغيير الجذري من الذين
يناصرون النظام البيت هؤلاء هذه كلها قوه
ستكون معاكسه للفتره الانتقاليه واستسعى
الى افشالها يجب عليهم ان يفوتوا عليهم
الفرصه وان يتوافقوا مع الذين اصلا يرغبوا
خليني اسمع التعليق الاستاذ الشريف لكي
يوفقوا لكي يعززوا التوافق ما بين الدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه
اسمح لك ببقيه الوقت تفضل
نعم انا كما ذكرت في وقت في وقت سابق ان
ان هذه العمليه السياسيه التي يعمل عليها
الاطراف المدنيين والعسكريين ومناقشه
قضاياتها قضاياها وموضوعاتها هذه العمليه
مستمره منذ اكثر من سته اشهر نعمل بكل جدو
باجتهاد من اجل الوصول الى صيغه متوافقه
عليها تريد تستعيد مسار التحول
على المقاطعه ولكن بسبب خلل تقني من
المصدر فقدناك لبعض الوقت شكرا لك شريف
محمد عثمان والفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين
شكرا لكما
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]